sorry das ist wirklich der hammer seit
mehr als 60 jahren sind sich forschungs
sieben sicher es muss eine super radiant
in festkörpern geben bei diesem phänomen
sorgt ein angeregtes atom für die abgabe
eines protons dieses einzige
lichtteilchen wiederum löst eine
kettenreaktion aus und ein intensiver
lichtblitz entsteht doch niemand konnte
das bisher nachweisen oder beobachten
jetzt ist die sensation gelungen klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
vielleicht hat es noch aus dem
physikunterricht auf dem schirm atome
gehen in einen angeregten zustand über
wenn man ihnen energie zuführt die
elektronen werden dann auf ein höheres
niveau angehoben und gehen dann später
wieder zurück in ihren alten zustand
dabei geben sie ein photon ab also ein
lichtteilchen der zeitpunkt dafür ist
überhaupt nicht vorauszusehen und das
ganze passiert zufällig anders dagegen
bei der sogenannten super radios hier
löst die abgabe eines photons unter
bestimmten bedingungen direkt eine art
kettenreaktion aus wenn dann alle atome
in diesem bereich die überschüssige
energie abgeben und das innerhalb
weniger sekunden entsteht ein intensiver
lichtblitz das besondere hierbei ein
einziges photon reicht aus um diesen
super allianz auszulösen klingt
eigentlich eigentlich ganz easy und
tatsächlich bereits in den 50er jahren
wurde bereits dieses phänomen
vorhergesagt in der theorie jetzt ist es
einem forschungsteam aus der schweiz
erstmals gelungen dies auch bei einem
festkörper in einem experiment zu zeigen
dazu andreas ankara einer der
beteiligten forscher super radiant ist
nur dann möglich wenn man die atome in
einem bereich versammelt der deutlich
kleiner ist als die wellenlänge der
photon problematisch hierbei sind die
atom wechselwirkungen in diesem bereich
von wenigen hundert nanometern die die
super asiens behindern um das zu umgehen
setzte das forschungsteam auf spezielle
diamanten bestehend aus kohlenstoff
gittern mit fehlstellen konkret handelt
es sich um sogenannte light reading
vacancy gitter fehler bei denen statt
eines kohlenstoffatoms 1 stickstoff atom
eine stelle im gitter besetzt und die
stelle daneben unbesetzt bleibt um eine
super allianz auszulösen
müssen diese gitter fehler angeregt
werden denn sie reagieren besonders
ausstrahlung mit besonders großer
wellenlänge wie beispielsweise
mikrowellen dazu angerer
unser system hat den entscheidenden
vorteil dass wird dort mit
elektromagnetischer strahlung arbeiten
können die eine wellenlänge von mehreren
zentimetern hat daher ist es kein
problem die einzelnen defekt stellen im
radius einer wellenlänge zu
konzentrieren
und tatsächlich das experiment war
erfolgreich die energie der mikrowellen
pulse wurde von den guitar fehlern
aufgenommen und das system geriet in
einen meter stabilen zustand doch erst
als eine bestimmte schwelle erreicht war
reagierten die gitter fehler 309
sekunden dauerte es nach der mikrowellen
abschaltung als dann endlich aus dem
zentrum des diamanten ein photonen blitz
hervorschoss dazu heißt es in der
aktuellen studie
dieser supra die ans pult wurde eine
million mal schneller emittiert als bei
der normalen entladung eines night raw
janeway kensy gitter fehler und das ist
ein riesenerfolg für das forschungsteam
denn somit haben sie dieses schon so
lang vorhergesagte quantenphänomene auch
experimentell in einem festkörper
bewiesen und nicht nur das auch für sehr
praktische anwendungen könnte das bald
riesige fortschritte bedeuten dazu
ankara super radial spielt in der optik
eine prominente rolle wo es
beispielsweise die entwicklung von neuen
lesern mit super dünnen strahl ticken
ermöglicht unsere arbeit liefert nun die
grundlage für zukünftige
quantentechnologie darunter auch super
radiant feststoff laser das finde ich
wirklich hammer wie die kanten für sie
ganz praktischen nutzen bringt und
dadurch nahezu unmögliche dinge möglich
werden wir stehen wirklich vor einem
zeitalter unfassliche sensationelle
entwicklung denn durch solche
entdeckungen werden kettenreaktionen
ausgelöst werden wie in diesem beispiel
zum beispiel erstmal laser mit
superdünnen laserstrahlen entwickelt
können damit wieder ganz neue strukturen
gefertigt werden aus denen dann
vollkommen neue teile und werkzeuge
gefertigt werden können die dann und so
weiter und so fort ja und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür draufklicken
laserschwert bald wirklichkeit licht
wird wie materie und wenn ihr kein video
mehr zu diesen und
in anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
folgt mir auf whatsapp nur da bekommt
ihr von mir vor allen anderen das
neueste video ganz unabhängig von der
abo box hier auf youtube die ja bei
vielen nicht so ganz perfekt
funktioniert und gerne auch ein abo da
lassen und natürlich nicht die die
glocke vergessen bis dann bleibt dran